i've got a veteran's day talk at the
table it's about this day honoring
americans who have served in the
military
all branches all positions and one
former marine is saying that we should
be looking for ways to allow our heroes
to continue serving
here at home jake wood is co-founder of
the disaster relief organization team
rubicon
and author of the new book once a
warrior how one veteran found a new
mission closer to home
he spoke to us about the endless legacy
of war
and a new way to think about veterans
day
we called ourselves bullet sponges we'd
go out on these these counter insurgency
patrols in iraq and we would basically
just wait for
the enemy to attack us as a marine
sniper jake wood deployed to iraq in
2007
and then afghanistan in 2008 never far
from what the marines call the point of
friction our tours were tough they were
bloody
we took some of the highest casualties
of any unit across both of our tours
a fact that haunted woods parents and
him as well
my greatest fear was my mother burying
me
um i you know i
when i got back from my second tour my
dad hugged me at the the airfield
and he whispered in my ear that my mom
had painted the living room ten
different colors since i'd left
and he said i had to stop doing that to
her and i you know i took that to heart
but if wood had always been a somewhat
unlikely soldier a former college
athlete
seemingly primed for business school
what was even more unlikely
is what he did after leaving the
military in 2010
what was the plan at that moment there
was no plan
and that was the plan when a powerful
earthquake devastated haiti destroying
much of that country's infrastructure
and leaving countless in need i'm
sitting there i'm watching it unfold
and it just looked familiar wood decided
to self-deploy as he puts it
this right here is your silver oxide
gathering a small group of veterans
and flying down to help it just became
obvious that
this is what we've been doing for a
decade overseas and they've been doing
it ever since
haiti was the start of team rubicon a
non-profit co-founded by wood
that has since launched more than 700
veteran-led relief operations
including a big one out here on new
york's rockaway peninsula
eight years ago this place was under you
know
three feet of water and a foot and a
half of sand
after super storm sandy up ended life
here team rubicon built an on the go
operations center to put things right
this right here
this right here yeah so this this
nondescript parking lot right here
hundreds of veterans led the rebuilding
efforts coordinating thousands of
volunteers
we'd get our teams the equipment and
supplies that they needed and you just
see
you know all these people just stream
out and just kind of move across the
neighborhood
just going you know house by house to
help these people who needed it
and they soon realized that by helping
others these veterans were also helping
themselves i think what many veterans
suffer from when they come home
is a lack of purpose a lack of meaning
and i think service to others has this
opportunity to fulfill that
when you're deployed the stakes are
literally life and death when you come
home
and you're working a job the stakes are
probably if i do well i'll get a better
tv next year
there's definitely truth to that life
and death stakes became so
normal overseas the idea
that you know you've got a sales quota
to me
i mean you know if it's a high enough
sales quote i mean maybe you know
maybe that'll do it for you but i think
for a lot of folks they are looking for
something that's more consequential
with that in mind it was here on
veterans day eight years ago
when jake wood asked former service
members and is asking us
right now to reconsider the purpose of
this federal holiday
what does veterans day mean to you
veterans day
has evolved into something that's more
of an opportunity to demonstrate
to the country not what veterans have
done but what they're still capable of
we look at veterans and we're quick to
thank them for their service and that's
good
we should we should do that but you know
i think we shouldn't be afraid to ask
them to
continue to serve so what's so
interesting about jake's perspective is
he's saying
that that people who have crossed the
rubicon have made a commitment to
service and
and once they leave the military that
commitment continues and they want to
continue to have a mission here in the
u.s
and part of what team rubicon provides
is that mission that disaster relief
130 000 veterans have volunteered
in about 10 years since the organization
launched yeah but i loved the thought
behind it i had to look up rubicon
uh commit to a course of action which is
what you just said i i'm very impressed
with him and how tall is he
he's a very tall man played college
football yeah
yeah but i mean his mission is so clear
and i see where it helps
the people that he's helping but also
helping themselves yeah it works both
ways i also love the story about his
mother painting the living room ten
different colors
yeah yeah they're saying you gotta stop
doing this to your mom that's a poignant
one yeah it's a good book too it's
called once a warrior yeah
and he still is yeah he's still in his
own way
all right tony's conversation with jake
wood will continue on today's cbs this
morning podcast